today on the Matt wall show the White
House makes revisions to the Declaration
of Independence in support of abortion
rights quote unquote a major mass
shooting Falls rapidly out of the
headlines when the left's assumptions
about the Killer's motives proved to be
unfounded Tony Dungy one of the one of
the least defensive people on the planet
is condemned as a rabid extremist when
he reveals himself to be a Conservative
Christian the state of Arkansas bans the
word latinx from its official document
and a woman films and publicly shames a
man who she says harassed and
traumatized her at the gym but the
footage shows something else entirely
we'll talk about all that and much more
today from the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
with everything you have in your plate
earning your degree online seems
impossible but at Grand Canyon
University they specialize in helping
you fit your bachelor's Master's or
doctoral degree into your busy day from
scholarships to customize scheduling
your graduation team led by your own GCU
counselor provides you with the personal
support you need to succeed achieve your
goals with your personalized plan and
your team fully behind you find your
purpose at Grand Canyon University visit
gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
this weekend marked the 50th anniversary
of the Row versus Wade decision and for
the past half century of course row
anniversaries have been solemn occasions
times for sorrow and grief and for a
renewed resolve to bring an end to this
Holocaust of The Unborn but of course
this year it was a little different Roe
was overturned the decision has been
tossed onto history's proverbial Ash
sheep and so the occasion took on a more
celebratory and triumphant tone that is
celebratory and triumphant for everyone
except for the genocidal butchers and
their supporters who instead spent the
weekend deeply mourning the fact that
more babies are being born and fewer are
being killed very upset about that this
was the theme of Vice President Camilla
Harris's speech to Mark the event in
Tallahassee on Sunday and Her speech was
uh was notable for for one thing for
being basically coherent a standard that
she rarely needs in any public address
it would seem that her thirst for the
blood of The Unborn has the effect of
focusing her mind and allowing her to
string together multiple sentences in a
row that while vapid and stupid at least
resemble human language so she's able to
do that much at least yet the most
revealing thing in Camilla's speech
isn't what she said but what she omitted
listen I am honored to be with members
of the United States Congress who are
here
state and local elected officials
[Applause]
and all of the Coalition Partners who
are represented here
[Applause]
so we are here together
because we collectively believe and know
America is a promise
it is a promise
of freedom and liberty
not for some
but for all
a promise we made in the Declaration of
Independence
that we are each endowed
with the right
to liberty and the pursuit of happiness
be clear
these rights were not bestowed upon us
they belong to us as Americans
yeah so I don't mean to be a stickler
for details but there seems to be
something missing here a couple things
in fact the Vice President in these
prepared remarks composed by White House
speech writers mentions two of the three
fundamental human rights outlined by the
Declaration of Independence but leaves
out the first one that the Declaration
lists the White House specifically
decided not to mention that we have the
right to life which precedes our right
to Liberty and to the pursuit of
happiness
after all we cannot have Liberty and we
certainly can't have happiness or even
pursue it if we don't first you know
exist
the value and dignity of human life must
come before any other right or Liberty
uh those other rights or Liberties must
in fact be grounded in the inherent
value and dignity of human life or else
they're grounded in nothing and can be
swept away like you know crumbs on the
floor
not incidentally this is exactly what
the administration intends to do with
our rights and has been doing
you notice that Harris also chose to uh
skip over the the source of these rights
so she says that we are endowed with
them but doesn't mention who has endowed
them the Declaration mentions that
now endow means to provide or to give
this necessitates a provider a giver
in the next sentence she says that she
says to be clear these rights were not
bestowed on us but rather belonged to us
except that endow means to bestow that's
what it means they're synonyms saying
the rights were endowed not bestowed
it's like saying well I drove a car to
work not a vehicle it's a distinction
without a distance a difference
we can only assume then from the context
that Camilla means that the rights were
not bestowed on us by the government or
any man-made entity
they are not um
rights that can be fundamentally created
by political act or by vote she would
have to believe this in order to
complain about rights being taken away
by government authorities if rights are
given to us by the government then it
makes no sense to complain when that
same Authority removes them we could
advocate for the restoration of those
rights that we want but we couldn't act
injured or offended or like something
that belongs to us has been taken away
if rights are entirely created by the
government
then the government has the absolute
authority to abolish them whenever it so
chooses
and we have no logical or moral basis
upon which to complain about it
that's that's all true and Kamala Harris
recognizes it
she sees the problem with the conception
of human rights that relies entirely on
governmental authorities but she also
rejects the only coherent solution to
this problem the solution that our
founding fathers came up with they
didn't come up with it rather but this
is what they believed if the rights are
endowed
um and if because of this endowment they
now belong to us in such a way that even
our political leaders don't have the
moral authority to take them away then
that would mean a higher authority has
given them to us that would mean the
that would be the Creator that the
Declaration mentions
but Harris skips over the Creator part
because she knows that any recognition
of a Creator leads inevitably to the
conclusion that we are created beings
which would mean that every life in the
womb is a product of this same Divine
creation which would mean that abortion
destroys that which is divinely created
it would also mean that the mother who
chooses the abortion is not destroying
something that belongs to her but rather
something that belongs to God and that's
a very important distinction that that
Camilla Harris doesn't want to recognize
you cannot acknowledge the Creator
without acknowledging first a higher
moral order one that would probably
frown upon the Mass Slaughter of infants
and second the inherent value of human
life which is precisely the thing that
her speech is supposed to militate
against
now
this whole thing you know
with the speech is sort of being treated
as just another patented Kamala Harris
flub or gaff
but it's actually much more than that
nearly everything you need to know about
modern leftism is contained in these few
sentences in this one speech
are really contained in the sentences
and the words that she left out of it
this is an ideological movement whose
adherence
cannot even quote the Declaration of
Independence without making revisions to
it for fear that they might accidentally
contradict themselves
and what this really shows is that the
leftist project is totally incompatible
with the American project not merely
incompatible the the former seeks to
destroy the latter that is its project
this country is indeed founded on the
belief in fundamental human rights and
the sacred Dignity of the human person
who is created by a Divine being by God
none of this works without that belief
it just doesn't work it's the underlying
assumption that the whole Tower is built
on
without it the entire thing comes
Crashing Down
the really significant and probably
insurmountable problem that we have in
this country is that is that we live in
a nation
where half of the people if not more
don't share that assumption and to make
matters worse many of them don't even
really realize that they don't share it
the others like Camille Harris they
realize that they don't share the
assumption but they keep up the ACT
anyway pretending that they do
and so all of our debates in this
country are then grounded
in a premise
that isn't actually shared by both sides
of the argument and then we wonder why
the arguments never go anywhere
it's because we're pretending to have a
shared premise when we actually don't
every debate in this country I mean it
really boils down right every political
debate boils down to figuring out what
our rights are that's what every debate
really is it's what are our rights whose
rights are they it's that's what every
debate is that
but this assumes that rights exist
and that they matter yet this is an
assumption not shared by one side even
if many of them think they do share it
they don't
they go around screaming about their
rights but they don't believe in any
higher being that bestowed those rights
they don't believe that the Universe has
any moral order which gives any weight
to those rights and they don't believe
that rights-bearing individuals have any
value in the first place
in other words they they can make a
claim to rights but they can't explain
why any of us should care about the
claim
which is also why it is so hard for us
to explain to them why they should care
about our rights claims
now it's not as though
there's ever been
unanimous agreement when it comes to
Human Rights but in the past the
disagreements centered around the
question of what our rights are how they
manifest themselves even which rights
belong to which people
but now there is a movement seeking to
explode the entire framework
although not all of them fully
understand it that's what they're trying
to do
and and as always with the left while
they seek to tear the lid off of this
concept and empty of it empty it of its
meaning
they have no new meaning to replace it
with
Harris like any other leftist she speaks
passionately of Rights while removing
both God and the value of human life
from the discussion there am I making
nonsense of the very idea of Human
Rights
and then nonsense is All That Remains
they don't give us a a new way of
thinking about human rights they don't
have some revolutionary new
interpretation of our country's founding
Creed
all they know is that they reject
what everyone else believed up until
this point
as for what we should believe instead
they have no clue
they uproot the tree and then just leave
it there
Standing On Top of the soil to slowly
die and then fall over and Crush whoever
happens to be standing near it at the
time
that's the general leftist approach to
everything
and to Western civilization itself
and that's what Camilla Harris was
saying even if she didn't say it
now let's get to our headlines
you know men don't like going to the
doctor it's time consuming expensive and
in some cases embarrassing Rex MD then
is a trusted leader in men's Telehealth
they make it easy and inexpensive to get
generic and branded Viagra or Cialis
online no waiting room no embarrassing
trips to the doctor no insurance no
co-pays with just a few clicks of a
button you can talk to a medical
professional create a personalized plan
and get the products discreetly shipped
straight to your door within two days
Rex MD doesn't just offer ED medication
they also offer medications that help
with hair growth pain relief sleep aid
unlike other brands Rex MD is FDA
approved clinically tested and a U.S
licensed Pharmacy as well Rex FD has
already helped over 300 000 guys gain
confidence quickly and conveniently and
they're here to help you to take
advantage of their best deal yet at
rexmd.com Walsh and save up to 90
percent off by paying only two dollars
per dosage starter packs of generic
Viagra Viagra or Cialis are now
available to get started that's
rexmd.com for up to 90 off go to
rexmd.com for more details and safety
information
there was a major mass shooting over the
weekend and if you want to read or hear
anything about it now is the time to to
hear about it because it's about to fall
out of the headlines never to return
so the shooting happened in Southern
California at an event celebrating the
the Lunar New Year so most or all of the
victims were Asian which of course is
the fact that the media was very excited
about and they were excited about it I
mean they were when I say excited I used
that word intentionally
they're excited when they hear about a
mass shooting and uh and then they they
look into it and they say they want to
know who the victims are and um if they
find out the victims are you know people
of color quote unquote they're very
excited about it they're happy
uh because then that means that this is
something they can potentially use and
they don't need to wait for of course as
we know any of the other details before
they before they use it this is what led
many prominent leftists to assume
immediately that this was a hate crime
against Asians because why else there's
like there's no other reason why people
who are who happen to be Asian would be
murdered it's the only possible reason
just like with trans people as we know
uh the way they count the the the the
numbers every single trans person
murdered in a year is the victim of a
hate crime because there's no other
reason why a trans person would ever be
murdered and this this apparently is the
same with Asians but no other possible
reason must be bigotry must be a hate
crime and they decided not only that
but um it was a hate crime carried out
by a white person
now some of the leftists were slightly
more subtle in making this connection
some were more blatant but just a few
examples of the tweets and statements
that that went out you know as soon as
the shooting occurred
Chuck Schumer says I'm heartbroken by
the news of the shooting in Monterey
Park amid Lunar New Year celebrations
I'm praying for the victims their
families and First Responders we must
stand up to bigotry and hate wherever
they rear their ugly heads and we must
keep working to stop gun violence
Katie Hobbs governor of Arizona said
devastated by the news of Monterey Park
my heart breaks for the victims their
families and friends and all those
impacted by this gun violence during
Lunar New Year celebrations these mass
shootings can't continue and Arizona
stands United with the aapi community
against hate
Adam Schiff said ten dead in Monterey
Park I am sickened a horrific example of
needless gun violence with bigotry
toward aapi individuals as a possible
motive
so he just that was less sell he just
came out and said it possible motive
by the way at this point no one involved
in the investigation which had been
going on that you know at this point for
about 45 seconds nobody officially
involved had said anything about hate
crime as a possible motive this is
something that he came up with on his
own
the families are in my prayers as we
seek information by law enforcement
we'll never quit demanding real action
on gun safety and then uh of course our
friend Jank over at The Young Turks not
subtle at all my wife used to work at
Monterey Park where the mass shooting
took place no one is safe Republicans
are constantly spreading fear about
immigrants crime and drag queens but the
number one thing that makes us and our
children unsafe is their favorite thing
in the world guns
many more of those came from that's just
a sample
until the truth
as it sometimes does unhelpfully
intruded onto the scene uh they had the
scene you know this is what the media
does the police they they tape off the
crime scene and the media comes in with
with different sort of tape that's meant
to keep the truth reality away from this
scene because they've already set their
narrative we don't want any we don't
want any truth here
but the truth came anyway here's NBC
news with the begrudging update
the gunman in the deadly shooting at a
dance hall in Monterey Park that left 10
people dead and at least 10 other
injurers injured as they celebrated the
Lunar New Year may have been targeting
his ex-wife and may have had a history
of domestic violence the city's mayor
said on Monday
speaking with NBC news's Kate Snow
Monterey Park mayor Henry Lowe said he
believed the ex-wife had been at the
star ballroom dance studio when the
shooter identified by authorities as who
Khan Tran
opened fire at the dance hall he said
there appeared to be a history of
domestic violence and it was possible
the suspect had been targeting his
ex-wife but did not expand further so
just so you know who Khan Tron
is not the name of a racist white guy
from Alabama or something this of course
is the name of an Asian guy an older
Asian guy as it turns out the guy's 72
years old and he's now dead from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound
this was it would it would appear then
Asian on Asian crime although the Asian
part had nothing to do with it this was
a domestic dispute
uh not a dispute this was domestic
violence apparently
now
so a couple things here
first of all
I personally I am forgiving of people
who uh after something happens in the
news
they make educated assumptions or
guesses estimations about about the
event without before all the facts are
out
you know someone who goes something
happens and somebody goes a little too
far and they they say oh here's what I
think happened and but but their
assumption is grounded in their
understanding of reality and they say
that it turns out that they were wrong
now you should you should wait for more
information before saying anything about
an event like this but if you're just
Discerning something based on an
inference from statistics
then I don't think that's too outrageous
because most of the time you'll end up
being right
what makes the racist white guy you know
shot up a bunch of Asians Theory
outrageous
is that it was of all explanations the
least likely the least plausible
so that's the difference between the
assumptions that the left tends to make
versus really the assumptions that
conservatives will sometimes make
see conservatives anytime there's a
crime or mastering conservative is going
to make assumptions if they make
assumptions at all they're going to and
I'm not saying that we're innocent
they're making something but we're going
to make assumptions based on statistical
realities
we're going to say well 95 of the time
when something like this happens here's
the cause and so probably that was the
cause this it maybe it ends up being the
five percent where that's not the case
but our assumption is not ridiculous
it's not outrageous it's not even really
inappropriate
the left on the other hand they make
assumptions that are that are they go
right to the least plausible explanation
and they assume that one
they make assumptions that contradict
the statistical evidence
in fact that's a that's a virtue
this is a form of virtue signaling on
the left
to deny the statistics
to do the opposite of inferring
something based on statistical reality
to infer the opposite based on social
that's the virtue
um and that's what they did here
you know anytime there's a murder first
of all
any murder
in in almost all cases it's either going
to be domestic
or drug related or gang or crime related
so it's going to be in the drug gang
crime area
or it's going to be something domestic
that is the vast majority of all murders
are explained that way
there's only a small sliver of murders
that fall outside of that so it's you
know that's almost the entire pie chart
and then there's a little bit of a piece
of the pie that can be explained and
then there are other explanations
um so if you're going to make any
assumption at all
the most logical one especially with
this shoot if you're gonna make any
assumption at all the most logical
assumption would have been well probably
this is someone who knew someone there
and and you know was was lashing out
turns out that's what happened most
likely
but
even if it is a hate crime
well if this was someone motivated by
hate for Asians
a white guy was the least plausible
culprit
so the left is going through the least
plausible explanation which is hate
crime and then within the least
plausible explanation finding the least
plausible version of the least plausible
explanation
because if it if you were going to
assume that if you're just going to
assume well this must have been
anti-asian hate crime well then you
should have assumed there was a black
guy who did it because the vast majority
of violence against Asians I mean almost
all of it is committed by black men
that's the statistical reality almost
none of the violence against Asians is
committed by white people it almost
never happens
so in any given day
if there's anyone in the in the the uh
across the entire nation being assaulted
or killed because they're Asian
it's almost certainly not a white guy
doing it
rare number of cases it will be
so they went to the least plausible
version of the least plausible
explanation that's what they do
the other thing about this too though is
that um
well you notice about situation like
this is this this story as I said it's
going to fall out of the news cycle yeah
they still have the gun violence angle
and they'll play that up a little bit
but they don't
you know they that that that to them is
not as juicy as the hate crime you know
it's a white person that that they they
like that explanation more they like
that narrative a lot more look get a lot
more out of that the gun violence thing
they don't get as much out of it so this
this story will probably just go away
and what you see from that is that
the Democrats and the media the left
they just have they have nothing to say
about violence they have nothing to say
about human evil
if it can't be tied to bigotry and not
not bigotry but specifically white
bigotry
any kind of human evil outside of that
they have nothing to say about it
um
and this is largely political right we
know that
they prefer the white bigotry narrative
for political reasons for ideological
reasons we all understand that
but it's also more than that because the
white bigotry narrative it's a it's
exactly that it's a narrative it's like
a story
and so this is
part of the issue with having 24-hour
news in the first place is that they
always have to have stories to tell
there's not enough actual news to report
every second of the day so it's like
they've got stories and every few days
there's another story and they're
telling that story
but they lack any kind of
insight
even putting aside the political bias
biases they lack any insight into the
human condition they even lack
imagination
so they have they simply have nothing to
say about they have no narrative they
can come up with no story to tell about
human evil outside of the realm of white
bigotry that's all they've got
which is unfortunate because there's
there's um
with the entire story of human evil
white bigotry again very very small part
of that uh of that of that pie chart
there's the entire rest of the picture
that we never talk about
uh because they have nothing to say
speaking of human evil the White House
commemorated as as we've already
mentioned commemorated the 50th
anniversary of Roe v Wade we know that
uh Camilla Harris was out she was given
the speech they also had this bit of
propaganda from a quote-unquote abortion
provider that they uh posted to their
White House Twitter page on Sunday watch
this
it's awful having to tell patients I'm
sorry I have those skills but I can't
use them because you're not dying enough
yet for me to take care of you
my name is Dr Layla zahidi spung and I'm
a high-risk obstetrician an abortion
provider
all of the clinics in the state of
Tennessee closed on August 25th when the
complete ban went into effect
and I can tell you when I heard that Roe
had been overturned I was immediately
afraid for my patients and I was
immediately afraid for myself and
therefore I knew that I was going to be
put in a situation at some point or was
worried about being in a situation where
I was going to have to put my own
freedom and life at risk in order to
take care of someone and make sure that
they didn't die and that is a terrifying
place to be and I want to be able to
take care of as many patients as
possible and if I end up being charged
with a felony like I would have if I
performed an abortion in the state of
Tennessee then I may not ever be able to
practice medicine again not to mention I
could go to jail I am unable to provide
care that is both evidence-based and
saves lives oh what a hero but she just
wants to save lives she wants to save
lives by killing them for profit
talk about ignoring ignoring statistical
realities the way if if you didn't know
any better at all you listen to her and
the White House of course is hoping that
people that listen to this don't know
any better and um unfortunately
that that hope is well founded for many
ignorant Americans
so if you're in that group you listen to
that you would think
that nearly every abortion is a
life-saving procedure
that's what you would think
this is what she the way she tells it
she's an abortionist
and she's constantly got people coming
to her they need abortion to save their
lives every single one is life-saving
when in reality none of them are
that that doesn't exist
um
a life-saving abortion doesn't exist
only life-ending abortions
and as we have tried to clarify in this
show many times we have to continue to
clarify it
uh for all the people who are hopelessly
ignorant hopefully not hopelessly so we
can do something about the ignorance
but
abortion
is directly and intentionally killing
unborn human life that's what an
abortion is is when the the the purpose
of the abortion procedure is to kill the
life of the womb and there's no other
purpose it's just directly killing the
life
um
in the very rare cases
where a woman needs some sort of actual
medical treatment
that is intended to
help whatever is wrong with her
but that will
perhaps or even nearly certainly result
in the death of the child that is not an
abortion
these are two different things
you know it's it's kind of the
difference between principle double
effect versus ends justify the means
and Justified means is let's just kill
the baby because the woman wants us to
and it's going to make her yeah it's
gonna make her life easier that's and
just by the means
double effect means that you're you're
doing the right thing you're doing a
good thing you're giving a woman actual
medical treatment
um even if there's a possibility that
will result in some bad thing happening
like the baby tragically dying
so for example a woman has terminal
cancer you have to treat the cancer that
might have devastating effects to the
child that's not an abortion
all they ever do is conflate these cases
they're not the same thing
and of course she knows that
but she's a hero
he's going to continue performing these
abortions even if she has to go to jail
well if that's true that she continues
to perform then them in Tennessee uh in
spite of the fact that she could be
charged with felony and thrown in jail
and I hope that she is charged with I
hope she's thrown in prison for life
that would be fantastic
you know if they if they take that woman
and they put her in cuffs drag her out
of the clinic frog March her into prison
I would be standing there if they do it
I hope that they let me know so I can
stand there laughing in her face
I would take Delight in watching that
and in the suffering she feels and
knowing that she's going to prison
because she deserves it she is a mass
murderer of children
what you just saw there one of the most
evil scumbags on the planet
the lowest form of life
but if she continues to do it in spite
of that possibility it's only because
she does there's nothing else she can do
she's not a real doctor
it's like there's no other she can't
take
her abortion skill her skill of killing
babies and take it to some other field
of medicine it doesn't translate all she
knows how to do is kill human life but
in most other areas of actual medicine
the goal is to treat and heal human life
so she knows how to do the exact
opposite
there's nothing so she's got nothing
else
and that's the uh the buying she finds
her finds herself in
one other thing here on a similar topic
Tony Dungy former NFL coach now he's a
sports commentator he spoke at the uh
March for Life on Friday let's listen a
little bit of this
well those prayers were answered
damara's recovering now he's home he's
been released from the hospital
[Applause]
but what's the lesson in that
you know an unbelievable thing happened
that night a professional football game
with millions of dollars of ticket money
and advertising money on the line that
game was canceled why
because a life was at stake
and people wanted to see that life saved
even people who aren't necessarily
religious
got together and called on God
well that should be encouraging to us
because that's exactly why we're here
today
because every day in this country
innocent lives are at stake the only
difference is they don't belong to a
famous athlete and they're not seen on
national TV
but those lives are still important to
God and in God's eyes
well as you can imagine Tony Dungy being
a mainstream figure as in sports media
now it's been known for a long time that
he's a Conservative Christian
and um
for the most part he's able to get away
with that with being a Conservative
Christian because that's a thing you
have to get away with these days
uh because he's talking about sports but
here he has come out and
actually spoken out forcefully and it's
not the first time he's done it spoken
out forcefully and in public against the
murder of babies and so uh the left
they're just done with him sport the
sports media in particular
this comes from Fox it says Dave zirin
sports editor for the nation said he is
done with Tony Dungy and the way the NFL
NBC coddle his right wing extremism
that's what you just heard In that clip
extremism
ziren says Dungey is some is someone
venerated throughout the NFL world as a
man of character but has spent years as
an anti-gay bigot Zarin wrote he said
publicly and proudly that he would not
want gay football player Michael Sam on
his team he said over a decade ago that
he disagreed with the lifestyle of Jason
Collins the first out-active male game
player in the main for North American
Sports this is a Dungey staple calling
being LGBT a lifestyle even after people
have said to him repeatedly how hurtful
and outdated such a description is he
simply doesn't care and then ziren goes
on and talk about uh how terrible he is
if Dungey wants a show on The Daily wire
more power to him I totally agree
I mean I can't I'm not in charge of
these things but I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say that we would certainly
love to hire Tony Dungy if he's if he's
interested so uh it wasn't just Dave's
Aaron's a bunch of other people the USA
Today had this article
um taking issue with dungey's what they
call Selective intolerance the article
says what Dungey is not and where he has
far less Authority with which to speak
is a woman
how do you know he's not a woman how do
you know
who must consider an abortion for any
number of reasons but that did not stop
Dungey from invoking Hamlin's name
himself at Friday's anti-abortion March
for Life in Washington DC
prayer may have prayer may have helped
Hamlin in his recovery that we do not
know but Hamlin was also helped to a
great extent by the medical
professionals and the Bill's employee
and uh and those at the University of
Cincinnati Medical Center Bill's
assistant athletic trainer Danny
Kellington was specifically lauded by
the doctors who worked with Hamlin at
UNC after he was transported there
to Dungey it seems that the use of
hanlon's name is fair game but only in a
selective sense sadly dungey's selective
intolerance has been in the news far too
often in recent days
intolerance what is he intolerant of in
that in that speech there intolerant of
killing babies I suppose
it's just it's it's uh
funny when they try to do this to Tony
Dungy of all people because he's the
most wholesome and beloved guys like the
black Mr Rogers of the NFL he's just
that he's everyone loves him anyone
who's ever played for him loves him no
one has a bad word to say about him
which is very rare in any business or
industry that you could be in that
industry for decades and no one who's
actually worked with you or for you has
anything bad to say about you
um that's really all you need to know
about somebody like if that's the case
then that's a solid person that's a very
good person
so this is all he does it and then on
top of that he just he comes off like
this incredibly inoffensive kind sort of
gentle person
I don't even know what it sounds like
I've seen Tony Dungy on TV for years I
don't know what it would look like or
sound like for him to be angry about
something
and they're trying to take him and turn
him into this
rabid frothing at the mouth extremist
which is just pretty funny
here's a story from the AP News one of
Sarah Huckabee Sanders's first acts as
Arkansas governor was to ban most state
agencies from using the gender-neutral
term latinx or latinx tapping into a
debate that's divided has Hispanics
among generational lines
Sanders called the word culturally
insensitive in an order that's prompted
complaints from some critics who view it
as yet another attack by Republicans on
the lgbtq community yet her move may
have limited impact given that the word
has not appeared to be widely used in
the Arkansas governor government
um
it was among several orders that the 40
year old former White House Press
Secretary signed within hours of taking
office that were cheered by
conservatives including restrictions on
teaching critical race theory in public
schools and banning Tick-Tock on state
devices all of these are fantastic
rules that should be in place in every
state
the latinx prohibition gives agencies 60
days to revise written materials to
comply
so
that's what that's the story from Sarah
Huckabee uh Sanders
Banning state agencies from using the
terminal tanks which obviously is the
correct move
and the AP is trying to frame this as as
a controversial move it's
latinx is controversial it's divided
Hispanics along generational Lines no it
has not
it actually has been a uniting factor
for Hispanics because nearly all of them
agree that latinx is ridiculous
there's no generational divide here or
if there is one it is marginal
I think the last I saw it was uh maybe
like three percent
of Hispanics are strongly in favor of
using latinx or do use it themselves
and yeah that number is going to be
higher
so pretty much anyone who's Hispanic and
above the age of 30. like zero percent
of them have ever used that word
um there might be five or six of them
that have used it under the age of 30
but that's it
and this qualifies as a generational
divide according to the AP
when it is not
this is a word that almost none of them
use
and again really really can't use
because it doesn't it it doesn't work in
the Spanish language doesn't make sense
in the Spanish language
um now so I appreciate this move from
Sarah Huckabee Sanders although she she
almost almost
not to split hairs here but she almost
ruins it with the reasoning that she
gives and I understand why she uses
she's using this reasoning trying to use
the left's logic against them but but
that it never works to do that
so as mentioned in the article but this
is what she um she responded to that AP
article with this tweet said
I banned the use of latinx in government
because I will not permit my
Administration to use culturally
insensitive words that greatly offend
the vast majority of Hispanics no matter
what the liberal corporate media says we
will keep the radical left's agenda out
of Arkansas
now again I understand why she's using
that argument
trying to use the left's logic against
them they're the ones that claim they
don't they don't believe in cultural
insensitivity and so she's saying well
this is culturally insensitive because
you're trying to voice this change of
language onto a culture that doesn't
want it it's cultural colonialism which
it is and all that is true
but that's not really the reason
fundamentally why we oppose
this language change
we oppose it because it's arbitrary it's
ridiculous it's incoherent
it represents the left co-opting
language for their own ideological
benefit
that's why we oppose it and the problem
with framing it as oh it's culturally
insensitive
is that okay well
the the left they're going to keep
drilling this home that's what they
always do with with changes of language
they keep drilling it and drilling it
until it gets through they keep beating
you over the head with it until you
until you bow into submission and so
what if 10 years now from now 15 years
from now
there
indoctrination campaign on this topic
has been
successful
and a slim majority of Hispanics say
that yeah I'm okay with the term
does that mean that now we're going to
put it into government documents
the word that was incoherent
and that representative the represented
the radical left's co-opting of language
does that now become okay in a
government document
because 56 percent of Hispanics say they
like it
no it's just as incoherent and radically
leftist as it was before
so you have a good solid objective
argument against this but you frame it
subjectively trying to use the left Zone
logic against them and when you do that
you end up shooting yourself in the foot
every single time
you you cut yourself off at the kneecaps
really it's not even at the foot you cut
yourself off the kneecaps
um
and it and it never works
so we have to understand the left's
logic can't be used against them because
part of their logic part of the leftist
logic is that
you know is that they get to decide what
all these terms mean
so yeah they're opposed to cultural and
sensitivity
but they're the ones who decide what
that is
and they have said that it's not
culturally insensitive to try to co-op
the Spanish language and force them to
adopt this word
as far as they're concerned they've
decided it so that's what that's what it
is that doesn't qualify as culture
insensitive
so that's the problem let's get now to
the comment section
it's all about
it
again
[Music]
uh child booney says I'm a 43 year old
infertile woman I've tried everything
medically possible to conceive a child
but it wasn't possible it breaks my
heart that medical research is even
being done to help men get pregnant when
there are real women suffering every day
that's an important angle of this as
well that we were talking on Friday of
course the show opened with the
Frankenstein gender surgeons who now
want to take the uterus out of a woman
and implant it into a man in hopes that
he can somehow conceive a child and give
birth we talked about all the
all the
scientific and logistical problems with
that not to mention just how ethically
and morally
horrific it is
um
but then yes it just goes to show that
the medical industry there there they
are right now working on the problem of
how to make it so that men can give
birth
to babies meanwhile there are lots of
women
who should be able to give birth to
children but because of various medical
complications they can so how about
taking all of that energy and all of the
um
funding and all the time spent the
research and spending it making sure
that every woman is able to to uh
conceive and bear and give birth to
children
how about that for an idea
now I will say that even in the cases of
a woman
um I would be
to put it mildly very skeptical of any
kind of uterus transplant situation and
the primary reason for that is the one
we talked about on one of the ones we
talked about on Friday
which is that this this is what it would
start off as being experimental as any
kind of new organ transplant is and but
usually with an organ transplant even if
it's experimental they haven't done it
very often
um you're taking you're assuming the
risk for yourself
right if it's some sort of radical new
surgery and and you say okay I'm gonna
undergo this surgery
because I have no I have no choice I
think it's worth the risk if it goes the
wrong way then then you know you've
taken that calculation you suffer the
consequences for that
but any kind of uterus transplant
there's going to end up to be end up
being another life involved in this
experiment
so you know there's going to be a what
happens to the first child who is
consumed conceived inside a transplanted
uterus
nobody can say whether that's going to
be safe for the child we just wouldn't
know
and so now we're experimenting with the
child's life as well
um
so that that is a major ethical problem
to me
no matter who you're transplanting the
uterus into
transplanting into a man just makes it
the whole thing into a horror show
kanty bloke says Ben passing that Dr
Phil spot to Matt was a cool piece of
trivia we got out of this fun drama I
don't know how fun the drama is but yeah
that is I think I've mentioned that
before but that is that's true the
people the doctoral producers they uh
they got a hold of us here at the daily
wire last year like late November early
December and yeah they wanted Ben to do
this
and he turned it down to pass it to me
not because he couldn't have gone in
there and
absolutely nailed that segment as well
but um because he thought it'd be a
great opportunity for me and this is the
kind of thing that
you know when I talk about what goes on
here at the daily wire I know if you're
not in the business you're not in the
industry you have no frame of reference
but so all you could do is just take it
from me okay
but I'm telling you that this is the
kind of thing that makes me appreciate
working at the daily at the daily wire
and that separates it from like any
other company in this business that you
have people here who say well this would
be a great opportunity for me but I'll
give it to you because I think it'll
really work for you that it just doesn't
happen I mean where else and that's the
kind of uh
mentality that you that you find here
and it is it is rare is what I'm trying
to tell you
and why is this because people actually
care
I'm not saying this is the only company
that employs people who really care
about the culture and about about
winning the culture
but um
that is much more of a
of a clearly motivating factor here than
it is I would say anywhere else and I've
been other places
and I've been around a lot of other
places
foreign
budgie bird says I agree with you on
cake Matt we had a fall wedding and had
an entire table of Pies apple pie pecan
pie pumpkin pie cherry pie blueberry pie
strawberry rhubarb pie we cut the
wedding pie instead of the cake my mom
gave me grief about serving pie instead
of cake but guests still mentioned 14
years later how awesome it was to eat
wedding pie instead of wedding cake
so this is a movement that we are
you and I are starting together
get rid of cake
and still you know give it a cake
replace it with pie
and in my perfect
version of the world Pi doesn't even or
cake doesn't even exist anymore because
there's no reason for it
serves no purpose
another comment says what is a woman is
locked behind a subscription paywall
Matt Walsh claims he hates bubbles but
his documentaries quite literally the
definition of a bubble the only people
who watch it are already people who
believe in it the people who needed to
see it the most will never watch it
because they'll never buy a DW
subscription they didn't make the
documentary to save the culture they
made that documentary to grift people
into daily wire subscriptions extremely
scummy strategy you can't you can say
well it takes money to buy to make a
documentary except you literally can't
rent the documentary just flat out pay
for it the only way you can watch is
through a DW subscription
they lock Candace Owens behind a paywall
so how is that helping the culture they
spew out ads every three minutes on top
of having full YouTube ads and that's
still not enough money to make the
candle selling show free to watch
actually it is free right now
um there are grifters bro I'm sorry
you've been fooled so this is
interesting I see comments like this I
just want to respond to it because uh
you notice with people like this
and there's a lot of these people out
there in the world and not just
commenters on YouTube
but they they literally cannot be
satisfied no matter what so you're out
there doing things and succeeding no
matter what you do
it will not be good enough or right they
do nothing they're not doing anything
you're doing something
but whatever you're doing you should be
doing something else
so you see the the Trap that's laid here
which I think is really interesting on
one hand it's a grift and a scam to have
a subscription service I don't know does
that just apply to us or is that
everybody is every Subscription Service
a scam saying okay we have this these
products that we're making you can
subscribe and have access to them that's
a scam now
I wonder if you apply that to everyone
or if it's just us like we're the ones
who aren't allowed to have them but at
the same time so you don't like the
subscription but the Santa you also
don't like the ads
so we can't have subscribers without
grifting and scamming we can't do ads
without grifting and skin
what how do you want this to work
exactly you do realize it it does
require money from somewhere to do any
of this
but there's just there's nothing you can
do nothing you could do at all and also
they want us to be to to free ourselves
from Big Tech
dependents which we all agree is the
ultimate goal
but anything we do to get in that
direction is not right
part of getting there is to have your
own subscription your own platform
that's how you get there that's how you
that's how you become not dependent on
big Tech which is a huge goal in
strategy given that these companies own
everything
and they have since the beginning of the
internet
and so to change that is a massive
revolutionary act really but it requires
time as I said on Friday also requires
money and requires uh investment
from everybody involved
if you want to make the investment you
don't want to give daily wire your money
to be subscriber that's perfectly fine
you don't have to
but don't sit there on the sidelines and
complain that we're even attempting it
yeah
or you can but the complaints don't
really mean anything because we're gonna
forge on ahead
this month we're celebrating the
anniversary of one of the greatest
moments in Daily wire history after
months of us leading the legal battle
against the federal government and a
national do not comply campaign the
Supreme Court ruled in our favor and
blocked the bite administration's
outrageous vaccine medic this mandate
would have said a dangerous precedent
giving the unelected OSHA power power
over the personal medical decisions of
American citizens Supreme Court
recognized this gross power grab and
they made the right decision and so we
are proud to have led the charge in this
fight but we couldn't have done it
without you thousands of you joined the
daily wire and over a million Americans
signed our petition against the mandates
to celebrate we're offering 40 percent
off on all of our annual memberships
with the code do not comply
um
and like we've been talking about the
last couple of days you know uh working
for this company we know we're fighting
for the culture we also know we can't do
it without any of you this is an
investment that uh that we all make
together and if you're not part of the
team yet then you can become part of the
team and celebrate one of the greatest
moments in Delaware history with 40 off
your annual membership join out
dailywire.com subscribe and join the
winning team as we continue to crush the
left remember do not comply for 40 off
do not comply now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
one thing we all know is that there is
no trauma quite like a Tick-Tock trauma
those traumas inflicted on and
documented by Tick-Tock influencers and
um used by those same influencers for
social media Cloud are by far the worst
traumas known to man nobody in the world
has ever known the sort of suffering
that this group of poor unfortunate
experience every day of their miserable
lives case in point take Tick Tock
vlogger Jessica who went viral over the
past a few days after posting a video to
her 600 000 plus followers revealing the
purported sexual harassment that she
encountered at the gym she also posted
the video to Twitter along with this
caption this is her caption she said
this guy kept making me extremely
uncomfortable at the gym this is why
I'll end up crying on stream because I
feel so grossed out at times with the
amount of sexualization I experience
hopefully this spreads awareness for
girls who experience this type of
treatment at the gym
in the thread below the video she
further explains that this man was
staring at her for quote disturbingly
long periods and that this triggered her
quote fight or flight response and
conjured up memories of quote previous
traumas
she emphasized that she's tired of being
sexualized and just wants to work out in
peace without anyone watching her
it sounds like
whatever happened exactly it was pretty
terrible I mean obviously this guy at
the gym he's a pervert and a creep he's
lurking off in some dimly lit Corner
staring conspicuously at her
that must be the case because the only
other possibility is that this woman is
a narcissistic drama queen and a liar
looking for ways to entrap innocent men
so that she can slander them on the
Internet for clicks and that just
doesn't sound like anything that any
woman on Tick Tock would ever do but
let's consult the actual video just to
find out here it is
this is how to not approach girls at the
gym
because I hate when they're sweet ass
makes me so uncomfortable
several cell feral feral like feral
there's mirrors everywhere so it's like
you can easily cat catch people
oh this is nothing
okay we're gonna move on to the 35 now I
want you to watch very carefully
yeah this is five as five pounds
is it great
excuse me you don't have to do that it's
okay no no it's okay I got it thank you
though
ah okay so
he glances over in her Direction a few
times uh for less than like half a
second at a time and then finally walks
over and tries to help her put the
weights on the bar and she declines his
help and he says okay
and then he walks away the end and they
all live happily ever after well I mean
he does maybe but she walks away
traumatized crying and shaking barely
able to hold herself together because a
man briefly noticed that she exists
now before we analyze this incident one
thing you should know is that this video
is one installment in an Ever more
popular genre on social media there are
apparently many videos of men quote
harassing or quote staring at women at
the gym these incidents are usually
captured in the same way there's a woman
at the gym filming herself working out
for whatever reason and in the process
she catches some man in the background
quickly looking in her Direction she
isolates the clip post it to the
internet and then shames the offender
for his conduct
here's just one more recent example I
got some attention a couple months ago
of this sort of thing as I said there
are many others where this came from and
this one a tick tock influencer named
Adriana claims to have captured footage
of a gym employee quote being a pervert
and gawking at her while she takes her
shirt off and you may ask well what the
hell are you doing taking your shirt off
in the middle of the gym we'll get to
that in a second but um anyway here's
the video
stand up for myself he threatens to call
the police and revoke my membership
do you need something
do you need something do you need
something
okay I thought so
[Music]
you can leave
this is why we need sex segregated gyms
we just do like male and female gyms uh
that that's a solution to all this stuff
because let me tell you something no man
at the gym been to many gyms in my life
men are not looking for any kind of
drama at all they're just there doing
their thing and they're not looking for
any of this just like if you're there
and you want drama and gossip and you're
looking for problems and you want to
leave and have something to talk about
to your friends well guess what happened
at the gym no man wants to leave the gym
with that kind of story guess what
happened at the gym
that's something that some women look
for and so we just need to be in
separate ships just do your own thing
that's what we need
in this case once again uh he looks in
her general direction from what might
add up to like one and a half seconds
total although she slows down the she
puts it in slow motion
to make it seem longer
and this makes him a pervert deserving
of public shaming he glances over at a
woman
taking her shirt off whether or not
that's the reason he glanced she decided
to do that and that's he makes he's a
pervert now because of that
now let me just make a few points here
first there are many reasons why a
person might look in your direction
while you're out in public
these women because they're raging
narcissists with a severely inflated
sense of their own importance and their
own physical attractiveness just assume
that any person who looks at them must
be admiring their beauty but
particularly in the in the first video I
can easily imagine several other
possible explanations he might have been
looking because he was wondering why the
woman was filming and muttering to
herself like a schizophrenic he might
have been feeling self-conscious because
he knew that he was probably in the
background of her shot
he might have been thinking to himself
she's not filming me is she
and turns out she was
or he might have been glancing over
because he wanted to turn with the
equipment that she was using and was
waiting for his chance to swoop in as
soon as she moved on okay he may have
been frustrated because he's trying to
get his workout in and he's got this
woman sitting there filming a social
media video with the damn equipment he
wants to use
you know that's that that is something
that happens I had this experience at
the gym over the past weekend I was
using one of the benches over the
dumbbell station while there was a guy
who's kind of lingering in the
background staring over at it was just
me there are other people using the
benches and he's like staring over and
continuously sort of you know looking
and then you look back and I didn't
assume
that he was looking at me because of my
striking good looks I also I didn't even
assume that he was looking at me and
thinking hey isn't that the what is a
woman guy the latter possibility was
much more likely than the former but
instead I assumed that he wanted to use
the bench that I was using
and uh then I got up and he staked his
claim to it as soon as I was done
confirming my theory so this is all very
normal and fine in a gym it's what
people do and nobody has to be publicly
shamed over but let's say that in the
case of these women
the offending men really were looking
over at least in part because they found
the women physically attractive
so what
okay that still would not constitute
harassment much less would it make them
perverts it would just make them normal
men whose only sin is merely noticing a
woman
this doesn't make them you know this
doesn't make doesn't make them harassers
doesn't make them perverts it just makes
them men with functioning eyes is what
is all it does
second thing here's a tip if you're a
woman
and you don't want to be noticed by men
if indeed even the brief glance of a man
offends you and causes trauma
then you might consider wearing clothing
when you go out in public
now I'm not saying you you need to cover
yourself in a burlap sack or hit the gym
in a parka and snow pants but I am
saying that you probably want to wear
more than just your underwear
so both women are working out in skimpy
spandex shorts and a sports bra a
uniform that has become by the way quite
common at gyms all across the country at
some point in the past few years the
nation's women decided by majority vote
I guess that clothes are optional when
working out in public and yeah according
to the laws in most States apparently
they're free to treat the gym like a
nudist resort if they so choose but
they're not free to control everyone
else's minds and eyeballs while they
perform a striptease at Planet Fitness
the woman in the second video she
actually strips down to her underwear in
the middle of the gym
they have locker rooms for that purpose
but she chose to do it in public
perhaps next she'll give herself a
sponge bath while standing on the
treadmill I mean who knows the thing is
you don't behave this way and dress like
that unless you want attention
you can claim otherwise but you're lying
you dress that way because you want
attention period
there is no other possible motivation
for walking around in public in your
underwear if anyone does that man or
woman you're looking for attention
depending on
what you look like and whether you're a
man or a woman and all the rest of it
it'll determine what sort of attention
you get but you're going to get
attention if you walk around in your
underwear
If any man you know men don't do that do
you notice that men aren't rolling up to
the gym in their underwear like when's
the last time you saw a man at the at
the gym
wearing just box or shorts and nothing
else
I've never seen it
but guess what if a man did do that
people would be stuck women would be
staring
maybe because they find him attractive
or maybe because they're thinking what
the hell is that guy wearing to the gym
but here's the thing with these with
these women they want to control they
want the attention they want the
attention but they want to control
exactly what sort of attention they
receive and from whom and for how long
and in what way they want attention but
it must be a tension that fits their
mood at any given moment and that's just
not how this works okay life does not
work that way no matter how much you
wanted to it doesn't if you go out in
public and say hey everyone look at me
they're going to look and you're not
going to get to control who looks for
how long all the rest of it
speaking of trying to control the type
of attention keep in mind that these
women are recording their workouts to
put on social media they're supposedly
self-conscious about being watched yet
they're posting the footage to the
Internet so that thousands of people can
watch it
they don't want to be noticed while they
work out so they work out in their
underwear on camera
there seems to be a logical disconnect
here
but it's a symptom of the disease that
we just talked about people these days
not just women on Tick Tock though
especially them perhaps are desperate
for attention they're starving for it
all the time and yet while going out of
their way to solicit the attention of
countless strangers they still think
they should be able to control the
manner and duration of the attention
most of all they want all the attention
to come through a screen
so they're standing in a room with other
human beings
demanding the attention of everyone who
isn't in the room while wishing to be
invisible to everybody in the room
if anything is perverse it's that
attitude
finally ladies
if you're wondering why you aren't
meeting any decent men out there it
might have something to do with this it
might be because they're afraid of being
publicly shamed as rapists if they even
so much as glance in your direction or
God forbid try to speak to you
if a man could potentially be a pervert
simply for noticing your presence in a
room
if he commits harassment by trying to
initiate any kind of conversation or
interaction at all then the game is
hopelessly rigged against him and he
loses automatically
more and more men will decide just not
to play the game it's not worth the risk
and that's exactly what's happened
and that is why
and that's all Happening by the way
thanks to women like Jessica and Adriana
and that is why they in particular are
the ones who are today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show let's move over to the members
block if you're not a member you can
become a member today use code Walsh at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign